this season of sex ed is brought to you
by Lilo Lilo makes one of the world's
best sex toys and they are champions
sexual wellness and education
[Music]
Lilo believes in owning and exploring
your sexuality destigmatizing
conversations around sexual education
discovering what self-pleasure means to
you and Bridging the orgasm gap which is
why we are so happy to be partnering
with them on this season of sex ed stick
around until after the episode to learn
a little bit more
does your father expect you to tell him
when you're not a virgin
foreign
do you think I'm a virgin no
no
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna hand you these whiteboards I'm
going to ask you guys questions and
you're gonna write down the answer and
then you guys will show it what age is
appropriate to lose your virginity
laughs
let me stop
you don't even know how to wash the
dishes
[Music]
oh my God I was a late bloomer
I haven't yet it's a question mark
I don't even want to [__] know I
don't want to know I don't want to know
how how many people do you think the
other person has slept with oh we're
talking about domestic no not for it
or International
[Music]
wow
let's not save the other person is
correct
[Music]
me yeah
stop stop oh my God they're gonna watch
this and they're gonna be like is that
Ernesto he got old
which parent gave you the sex talk
I dude we didn't have it never did never
did we just don't talk
it's not a joke
he literally gave me the dictionary and
told me to look up words
uh you were really into baking so we
used the cake analogy that the father
has some ingredients and the mother has
some ingredients my mom one time brought
up birth control but that's as far as
we've ever gotten sex talk wise so I
wanted to have the sex talk with my mom
but she's like no talk to your dad so he
gave all the siblings the sex talk yeah
I gave a sex talk I want my daughter to
be safe when it comes to things not just
pregnancy just you know Predators or
what have you
how do you know when someone is ready to
have sex
the age of consent look I do think
there's a maturity level that I believe
that you had I was comfortable knowing
that you had sex and that you were
mature enough I think one they'll tell
you and when they think it's right and
it's the right person that they're in
love with you know it happened for me
real young and I thought it was really
cool and now that I'm a dad I think well
what a little you know I wouldn't want
it to be the same for you I wouldn't
want it to be meaningful not pressured
not because you're drunk not because
someone took advantage of you it really
depends on the person because there's
been people like my current significant
otherwear I literally like knew within
hours but there's folks that I've like
waited for a long amount of time and
then had sex with them and it didn't
feel right and so like this whole like
winner you ready I think like you know
that internally
um and like sticking with your like
moral compass there
do you know one another's birth control
regimen
I went to the doctor on my own when I
was a teenager and then I asked him to
pick up medication from the pharmacy and
I forgot that they were giving me my
birth control and he was just like
no I don't know I started this year
birth control
um I'm not really feeling it just
because I don't really like how it makes
my body feel so I'm trying to see if I
want to just not take it or find a
different kind condoms
and I'm
going to get snipped really yes I don't
want any more kids
what would you do if I were to come home
pregnant
drink and cry first I think after that
I'd um I mean I support you I mean I
want to stand behind you anyway and I
wouldn't be mad that would be the last
thing on my mind is getting mad at you
and I always knew that I have something
big like that even happened they'd
rather know so they can keep us safe
rather than us hiding it I would just
ask you are you ready
if you're ready and you said yes fine
who is the father if you don't know the
father what can I do is he going to
marry you if you don't know the answer
then we will raise the kids that's
normal life I love how in all these
scenarios it's worst case scenario it's
never like oh my goodness somebody wants
to marry you and have kids with you I
mean ultimately it would be her decision
obviously I'd be upset and it would be
her decision I would
push for an abortion you would yeah I
would I just think that she's too young
to to raise a kid I always told myself
that like I would want to keep it but so
I always wondered like would you like
support me like why I would have to
support you because it would be your
your decision if I ask you for help like
financially and stuff like would you
help me or like if I needed like I would
help you you would yeah I was always
scared of that I'd have to I'd have to
help you oh thanks
have you ever discussed consent with
your daughter
we discussed that a lot because it's a
it's my job it's her job yeah I work in
women's health and around sexual assault
survivors so it's a huge like point of
conversation but it was not a point of
conversation growing up like so like you
said like you don't want anyone is
taking advantage of me and stuff it's
like me being conscious enough and like
not being pressured into anything I'm
kind of Hardcore about this one
um you know we're talking about that
boyfriend you had back in high school
high school so when everything came to
light and I found out that he had kind
of pushed his self on my daughter it
really pissed me off and you either
gotta grow up or teach your kids how
they need to treat someone else you know
I I'm sorry but I know I've been kind of
Hardcore about that one but it's a good
thing to be hardcore about it is I mean
it just is knowing what I would hope her
boyfriends would the way they would I
would want them to act put also a you
know additional thoughts in my mind of
that I should act the same way too
how do you feel knowing your daughter is
or is not sexually active
I am like worried because
you have to think about safe sex
let's be honest nowadays safe sex safe
sex safe sex you need to be healthy
that's really you know intense for you
to say that because in the Philippines
when somebody has an STD or pregnancy
and you're unmarried it's it's a social
suicide kind of thing and for him to say
that that he wants to still talk to me
and support me I didn't know that this
kind of talk this kind of thing
happening you get disowned it's a part
of life it's it's nature it's bound to
happen I feel like you know relief that
we can have this open communication
because I didn't my mother and I we had
good conversations but we really didn't
go in depth and my father he my
stepfather he didn't talk to me about
the birds and bees or what have he was
just always going to Dodger games or
whatever you know the wood but not the
wood so
what's something you wish your parent
taught you about sex
the it is beautiful
first of all it is something like you
need to have it and learn how to be
you know interact while you are there I
wish my parents told me it was a
beautiful thing
because I've had moments when it wasn't
exactly a beautiful thing and
when it became something beautiful I
didn't know it could be something like
that
that there should be no shame
I wish my mother would have told me that
like more in depth of talking about how
serious attachment can be after
sometimes you're going to feel like
if that person doesn't talk to you
anymore like it's the end of the world
oh yes I think that I think has been the
best thing between us is being able to
listen to them and not react uh in sort
of the the ways that maybe fathers would
be reacting by either getting mad or not
wanting to hear it at all sometimes it
was hard for me to hear things that you
were telling me but I knew that if I
reacted or
downplayed it that maybe the next time
you wouldn't bring it up at all
three two one good
hi
I thought I would recognize at least one
thing it's like the spectrum of the
rainbow
for your private parts
I don't know what this does I feel like
this is like the Conch Shell from Lord
of the Flies
I'm guessing that's a suction
mechanism on a certain region and could
make someone very happy oh it's so
different on your face than your hand
these aren't used right this is
literally a mystery
Street of extra soft body safe silicone
eight pleasure settings and it has a
wider Mount to fit a range of anatomies
and stimulate the entire clitoris
that's the official medical term it has
a pretty big mouth which is nice I also
like the lavender
your pleasure is your own and Lilo knows
it educate yourself about your own body
first in order to enjoy sharing it with
your partner go to lilo.com to learn
more and now that I know what this is I
very much want to practice
[Music]